uh and i'm sharing my screen i hope
that's that's all right yeah we can see
it
i guess yeah okay cool i was just gonna
say the cursor is on the front of the
slides but no it's not great
um yeah so uh whenever you're ready
basically yeah thank you
very excited to to be here sorry i can't
be there in in in person
um but i'm going to be talking to you
about uh rewards and multi-agent systems
um
and uh just to uh to say a bit more
about this i think multi-agent systems
actually
offer a really interesting playground
for reinforcement learning agents
um because these agents need rewards and
an interesting life basically in order
to to learn and and to develop
interesting behaviors
um and one way to obtain this is to have
other agents in the environment and to
interact with them and to use these
agents uh both as a source of basically
non-stationary
but also as a source of of reward
and so
the talk that i'm going to to give is
basically trying to understand how we
can leverage other agents
in order to to make these environments
for for rl
and i'm going to show you first a case
study of a particular way of leveraging
rewards from other agents which is to
use a gifting mechanism this is mainly
empirical work that was done in
collaboration with my master student
andrei lupo and then i will
talk a little bit about some theoretical
ideas in reward design
where we've taken some initial steps
and there are actually lots of
other opportunities
and maybe some of the people
participating can get interested in this
problem and you know i'd be very glad to
to talk to them more about it
so uh gifting in multi-agent
reinforcement learning is a mechanism
that we've tried to
explore a little bit
uh for a common tool resource
appropriation problem so this is a
problem where you have resources these
resources can renew and they're consumed
by the agents whenever the agents
consume these resources they get rewards
but the resources only continue renewing
if you have a minimal density that's
maintained and otherwise you know things
collapse so you can think of this as for
example if you're farming
if you're over farming right at some
point the earth gets depleted and
there's no more crops
and so if you have this kind of over
consumption
the pool of resources becomes depleted
and this leads to tragedy of the commons
types of phenomena
where uh you know the agents none of
them can can really do well anymore
because no rewards are any more
available
and so the main idea that we try to
explore here empirically is
whether we can use sort of gifting
mechanisms between the agents in order
to
entice them and encourage them
to avoid this kind of over consumption
behavior and so the idea is
rather than having sort of a centralized
mechanism
individual agents can choose to give a
positive reward to some other agent in
order to incentivize them to
do a desirable behavior for example not
to to consume too much
now why gifting because gifting is
really very pervasive in in human
economy uh you know throughout history
if you wanted you know the ruler of the
kingdom to to be nice to you you would
uh bring them some gifts
uh and even in animals uh you know the
in there's a certain hierarchy and you
know people who are lower in the
hierarchy bring gifts to uh to the ones
that are higher in the hierarchy
and it's also very consistent with the
core idea of reinforcement learning
which is that rewards are a driver of
behavior so you can think of these gifts
essentially as uh as integrated in the
reward signal that's coming anyway from
the environment it's just that now this
reward comes not from the environment
itself but from a different agent
um and in some sense if we could figure
this out it alleviates a little bit the
burden of figuring out a perfect
centralized reward
mechanism
and maybe the agents can figure out how
to improve the collective behavior or
the the learning speed by providing
these rewards more frequently to each
other and so the the
dense reward signal can also help
in terms of the learning speed so this
was sort of the motivation for for this
work
and now of course if you think about how
to actually implement it there's various
choices
for for uh gifting mechanisms and so we
looked in particular at three different
choices that seemed reasonable
the first one which i'm going to call
zero sum means that an agent can choose
a gift in action that just transfers a
certain number of units of of wealth or
reward to another agent
and this means that you know the the
target agent gets plus g
and the one that is giving the gift
receives immediately minus g right so
this is the sense in which it's zero sum
um
and you know you can now think of
whether you want to uh sort of allow a
finite budget or not but but this is
sort of the basic idea of what happens
on on one gifting action
the fixed budget idea is uh in order to
encourage agents to give without rest
sort of perceiving this as an immediate
problem and so an agent might have a
fixed budget and every time that it
gives a gift this budget gets
decremented when there's no more budget
it can no more give any gifts and the
recipient
receives immediately a reward of plus g
or g is the value of the gift
and then the third possibility is this
replenishable budget idea where we also
have a budget but it's really uh sort of
a fraction of the actual real rewards
that the agent receives so initially
there's no gifting budget but if an
agent
gets a positive reward from the
environment some fraction of that reward
goes into this budget and the agent can
choose later on to give some of that to
another agent and otherwise it's it's
the same as the other ones
so you know the the reason why we
thought about the fixed budget and
replenishable budget was that we wanted
to make sure that agents would not
perceive gifting immediately as somehow
a bad action that that should be avoided
and therefore uh sort of never do it
now in order to actually understand what
would happen if we introduce these
mechanisms we use this harvest domain
that
came from julian perola and colleagues
where you have some apples these are the
the green crosses in the picture they're
growing inside of a grid world
environment you have some agents in this
case there are there are 10 agents that
are the the red triangles that can go
around and each of the agents gets a
plus one reward whenever it eats an
apple
but the apples only renew if there's a
minimum density of other apples in their
vicinity and so if you eat a whole patch
of apples there will be no more apples
that uh that grow there
and these agents uh have in the original
implementation of the environment a
tagging beam the tagging beam
essentially
is like a weapon that incapacitates
agents in their neighborhood and
prevents them from from eating the
apples
but we added to this a gifting beam and
the gifting beam just takes a plus one
reward and spreads it around
uh to the agents that are within range
and so if you have uh you know only one
agent that's close to you you it will
get the entire reward but if you have a
couple of agents that are close to you
then this reward is going to be split up
among them
and uh this is all sort of uh the
parallel in terms of the training of the
agents the agents have a first-person
view of the environment
um
and so now we ran various experiments in
order to see which of these strategies
uh sort of prevent a tragedy of the
comments and what kinds of behaviors uh
come out
and so the first curves that i'm going
to show you are basically performance
curves these are the return uh per agent
in the in the left graph
and the sustainability and the right
graph sustainability in this case means
what is the average time between
positive environment rewards that the
agents are getting so not the rewards
that are coming from other agents but
actually eating apples um and in both of
these cases high is good okay
um
and we are training all these agents
with uh dq n which is very standard d
parallel algorithm with epsilon greedy
exploration and we compared
three different the three different
gifting mechanisms that i discussed and
also no gifting so that's the default uh
version of the environment that uh
julian perola had uh it's still the
agents still have tagging actions in
that version as well
um and so the first thing that i want to
say is that eventually all of the agents
learn how to do this task
and so all of the curves end up roughly
with the same performance but you see
this trough here in the middle
okay this is where the tragedy of the
commons happens for
all of the agents except the zero-sum
agent okay
so they they learn how to get rewards
basically by eating apples and then
they're they're overeating
okay and the production of apples
decreases so they go through this trough
where where they cannot get rewards
anymore um and then you know gradually
they learn a a reasonable policy
but this this agent that does the
zero-sum gifting never goes through this
drought and continues to sort of uh
improve improve throughout
so that's kind of interesting
um
now another question is could we have
avoided the tragedy of the commons uh
somehow anyway or is the gifting really
important in this respect so in order to
understand that
we actually took the the models that we
had trained
saved them at regular intervals and then
evaluated what happens
without allowing anymore the choice of
tagging and gifting actions okay just
allowing the agents to move around the
environment and eat apples
and in this case all of the agents do
collapse into tragedy of the commons
which is what we would expect because
that is a natural equilibrium in this
kind of problem
but the zero-sum gifting agents actually
collapse slower
and that's basically because early on
they learn these policies that exhibit
more restraint and these policies take
longer to sort of go away and and revert
to the nash equilibrium
now another thing that we looked at is
what kind of policies the agents learn
in terms of tagging behavior and and in
terms of gifting behavior so in terms of
tagging
as the tragedy of the commons starts
manifesting which is the first vertical
dotted line in this picture all of the
agents actually start tagging more right
because they're just trying to prevent
the the over consumption
but the zero sun gifting agents um
actually are pretty constant throughout
uh the only other interesting bit is
that at the very beginning they seem to
tag a little bit more
okay and that's really because of the
epsilon greedy exploration policy and we
think it's a side effect of that policy
in fact rather than
sort of a real phenomenon they learn to
tag because that means they're not going
to gift too much and get too many
negative rewards from the gifting
and
by the end they are still actually
tagging a lot less because there's not
as much problematic behavior right and
so they don't need to uh to sort of
exert this force
in terms of the gifting behavior the
gifting behavior eventually also goes
away
because by the end you actually don't
really have to disincentivize the other
the other agents from uh from consuming
okay
they just end up sort of occasionally
tagging other agents but you know
generally speaking being being
reasonable
um
and the agents that don't have a
negative reward for gifting continue to
give these gifts for longer this is also
reasonable because you know that nothing
costs them right whereas the agent that
actually pays for the gifts is sort of
uh stops uh to do that very early in the
paper we also analyzed uh the equality
among the agents like are some agents
you know ending up being more starved
than others and actually all of the
methods converge to roughly the same
measures of equality according to to the
genie index
so just to summarize this uh sort of
active reward sharing among agents can
really mitigate unwanted equilibria such
as uh tragedy of the commons there's of
course other ways to to achieve this
goal for example what might think of
setting up correlated equilibria uh but
maybe that's a bit harder to design
right it's it's a more centralized
approach whereas gifting is a very local
uh sort of per agent uh approach
um it's also interesting to look at
these behaviors and and what happens not
just the performance
uh because uh you know sometimes there
can be unintended uh sort of side
effects of of the strategies that we
have and it's interesting to uh to see
that
now you know this was purely empirical
work and it was in some sense heuristic
right and inspired maybe by by economics
but very much uh heuristic
one of the things that that i'm quite
interested in understanding
is uh the ways in which we can formalize
these notions of tasks and preferences
that other agents might have and express
them as rewards maybe even compute the
best rewards possible
so i'm going to show you now
sort of a bit of the different
flavor of work
that talks about uh the reward design
problem here we're going to take the
perspective of just having two agents
okay
and uh this is really based on a paper
that we published in eurips last year
and while i'm going to give you the the
high level of overview
the technical details are in the paper
so here we have two agents we have alice
which is this white agent here and we
have bob which is this this little robot
bob is a usual reinforcement learning
agent that acts in the world based on
the state that it observes and it gets
rewards and the rewards are provided by
alice and really alice is going to
compute this reward function
based on some notion of task that she
has in her head and so
a lot of what i'm going to talk about is
what are reasonable notions of tasks and
under what circumstances can we compute
an associated reward function
that captures the nature of the task
and so there's different task types
the three that that we discussed in the
paper
are uh the set of acceptable policies
policy ordering and trajectory ordering
and i'm going to uh sort of tell you uh
some examples and a bit of a definition
in each of them
initially we thought that this the sort
of the nature of the task is going to
make a big difference it turned out not
to make a big difference
so um
but i i still want to sort of convey all
of these uh to you
so what's a set of acceptable policies a
set of acceptable policies just says
here are some policies that are better
right considered better in the
environment so for example if we have a
little grid world navigation task we
might say reaching the goal in at most
10 steps in expectation
is the set of acceptable policies
okay
um and so you can think of this as a
constraint on policy space where the
good policies are all valued better than
the bad policies
policy ordering is something that
essentially
puts a partial order in policy space so
for example we might say i prefer that
you reach the goal in five steps but if
we can't do that it's okay if you reach
it within ten steps
and otherwise i don't really care
okay so that's a partial order in in
policy space
and then trajectory ordering talks about
particular trajectories perhaps in the
environment so for example i might say i
prefer this agent to reach the goal
and avoid the lava at all costs
okay so that that says you know the the
dark blue trajectories here are
preferable to the light blue
trajectories
so these are these are examples of each
of these task types
now
what does it mean for a reward function
to realize a notion of a task in order
to to define that
we're going to consider
an environment
which is a controlled markov process so
this means it's just like an mdp but
doesn't have the reward function
specified yet but there are states there
are actions there are markovian
transitions
uh between the states conditioned on
action and it's all fully observable
the task is going to be one of the three
types of tasks that we discussed
and we're going to say that a reward
function
realizes the task in the environment
if the reward function leads to a value
function an associated long-term value
function
that respects a set of inequalities and
so
for the set of acceptable policies
what we want is the value
associated with good policies to be
superior to the value of bad policies
okay and here we have an initial state
as zero so we're comparing the values
with respect to that initial state
but obviously this can be also done with
with initial state distributions
in policy ordering we want the value
functions to be ordered according to
this policy ordering that's been
specified and in the case of trajectory
orderings we would like the returns
along these trajectories to be ordered
in in the order pre-specified
so in this paper we explored two
questions okay the first question is
when can a task be realized in a
controlled markov process
um and so in other words we wanted to
know given any task and any controlled
markov process environment is there a
mark of reward that realizes the task
and actually the answer to that is
negative
okay and i'm going to show you
one example one case in which in which
this is not really true
okay which is if you consider this
little grid world
um
if you say something like uh you know i
prefer policies that always go in the
same direction
okay
this is actually not expressible through
a markovian reward
policy itself
is markovian
okay because you can sort of specify the
action
but the we can't really express this
because actually there is some
non-markovian information that's not
part of the state right which is
what have i been doing prior to arriving
here
and in order to sort of differentiate
the value of these two specific policies
always go left and always go right from
the value of everything else we would
need that kind of information
now you know is this bothersome from my
point of view it's not necessarily
because you know one way to think about
it is there's a mismatch between the way
that we've defined the state
and these preferences
okay
you know the preferences are on on
policies which are these sort of large
objects that have a global view of the
environment whereas the state the way
that we've defined it
is is too narrow if we added something
to the state for example if we
remembered some history about past
actions this would not be a problem
i still think that it's an interesting
question
how to sort of decide whether the state
information and the sort of
task information are actually compatible
with each other in general and
that may be sort of an open question for
future work
now the second question is uh
you imagine that i have an environment i
have a task
can we actually and imagine that that a
reward function exists could we actually
compute one and can we compute it
efficiently okay so we want the
procedure
by which we can you know alice can
ingest an environment and then take the
das that she has in her head and output
a reward function or output you know nil
if this reward function does not exist
and interestingly this problem can
actually be solved in polynomial time
for any finite environment and for any
of the kinds of task descriptions that i
have given you before
and the basic idea here
is to use a linear programming approach
okay and to uh to set up a set of
constraints that specify the task
um and then it's it's pretty
straightforward to show that this linear
program either has no solution for
example uh in the in the task that i've
i've showed you before
or that uh it can compute uh a solution
uh if one exists in in polynomial time
and that's this is because the program
itself is polynomial in the size of the
environment
now
these uh current results assume that the
designer knows the environment and knows
all the preferences in advance okay and
so this is a
very big assumption right basically
alice needs to know everything about the
environment that bob is going to be in
including the transition probabilities
but it would be i think really
interesting to think about an iterative
approach so
you might imagine that alice knows
something about the environment and has
some preferences computes a reward
function observes what's happening with
bob and then refines that reward
function right and that this is an
iterative process in which
both alice's computations on the reward
and bob's uh sort of computations of its
policy and value functions kind of
happen at the same time
that's that would be much more like a
sort of dynamic multi-agent uh game kind
of scenario
another interesting question here is
what happens if alice and bob actually
do not have the same features so here
we've assumed that they both know the
state space the state space is fully
observable
but really if we think about the deep rl
setting right bob might be an agent that
is learning something
and uh you know he's learning some
features and maybe alice has completely
different features because maybe alice
is an expert in this environment
i'm not sure if anything interesting can
be said in that case but it seems like
from a practical point of view an
interesting setting
and then finally sort of going back and
linking to uh to the gifting work
what happens if we have more than one
designer
so here we had alice but maybe there are
several uh sort of different agents that
have uh tasks in their heads
all about the same environment under
what circumstances can we come up with
some way of sort of generating a reward
function for bob
uh in an in an interesting way that that
still provides some uh some guarantees
so these are all good questions you know
we've barely scratched the surface i
think with this paper and i'd be
interested in chatting further and so i
will stop there and happy to take any
questions
awesome thanks a lot that was a i think
a really some really interesting work um
yeah it looks like we have a few
questions i'll go to costas
hi uh thank you
uh very interesting work i wanted to ask
you about the uh you claim the normal
time algorithm for a given task and
given environment
i wanted to understand
how you specify the task and the input
like what's the description complexity
of that
yeah so the task is specified in this
case by
imposing these uh inequalities on in
terms of the value function space
and so um
so basically what what are these linear
programs that we work with
um
the values
okay the value functions have to be in
this sort of relationship
the value functions have to be value
functions so they have to satisfy
bellman equations right that's a that's
a different um sort of set of
constraints
and then the the third ingredient here
is uh what i'm going to call uh sort of
uh fringe policies
so if you consider for example in the
set of acceptable policies all the
policies that are good
and then you consider all the policies
that are one action different from the
good policies
okay it turns out that the only
constraints that we really need
are between the good policies and these
fringe policies we don't need to care
about anything else
and so that's the set of value function
constraints
that ends up in this linear program
so just to be clear you would list all
the good policies and then say
you know these have to like you provide
a list of all the good policies and say
this have to dominate every other policy
is that uh
they they have to dominate every fringe
policy and that's sufficient
for them to also dominate all the other
policies gotcha so the
the former is the clever way you do it
but the constraint you want is that a
list of policies dominates all all other
policies correct yeah that's correct
except we can prune we can very heavily
improve the set of constraints by using
this notion of a french and in the
policy ordering you similarly will give
a list of policies and how they order
so the the policy ordering turns out to
be extremely similar
because really we just have a set of
these inequalities
of value functions now obviously if you
had
so
the the set of acceptable policies is in
some sense easier to to reason about
and initially we thought that it would
be quite a bit easier actually than
either policy ordering or trajectory
ordering but it turns out that in the
end
we still end up with linear programs by
sort of very similar reasoning
in these other cases as well and so
complexity
doesn't
really end up being
that different now i want to say a
couple of other things so first of all
in terms of the set of acceptable
policies
we could have partial specifications
in this case right so partial
specification might say
you know i don't care what you do except
at this state i prefer that you go up
instead of going any other direction
right so in this case we can you know we
can further perhaps uh be clever about
how how we enumerate
uh these constraints
and secondarily we have looked into
approximate notions
so you know you have to be you're going
to be better by at least a certain
amount right so so sort of like a margin
and that also
doesn't end up really being
fundamentally much different
um
although empirically
you know if if we have this kind of
margin
uh it makes it a bit easier to uh to
solve these problems in particular
environments well thank you
who else wanted to ask
hi thank you
with regards to the gifting work like it
seems to me that the
zero sum uh approach
actually is the the only one that
considerably does better than the no
gifting approach
but to me it also seems the hardest one
for the agents to learn so why is the
zero sum approach so much more
successful like is it like an intuitive
explanation you can give or
yeah so
you know i i also agree that and our
intuition was that it's going to be hard
to learn because you have these
immediate negative rewards
um
but so my sense is that actually
um
it's a combination of the specifics of
this environment
and you know having for example the the
tagging action versus having the gifting
action
and and the way that we do the
exploration all matter
and in this case the the agents you know
don't seem to care that much about the
immediate negative uh negative rewards
that they get from the gifting um and
they don't you know they don't select
the gifting action too much so they
don't become depressed about about those
actions either
i don't know if this would always
translate into into other environments
as well so i have the feeling that it's
also a bit specific
uh to to this particular kind of
environment but i was honestly quite
encouraged because
it is the it's the one that would make
most sense right
um even if it's uh even if it's the
hardest to learn i suppose that you know
there may be other
ways of uh you know maybe setting up for
example the replenishable
uh budget
right in a way that that would make it
better but we never got to explore that
um yeah because if i remember correctly
the original work from peru lutz it's
all um the official like final policy
that did not have the tragedy of the
comments was where they each tagged each
other often enough so that there were
less agents in the environment so they
basically could not eat all the apples
physically because they didn't have time
enough so maybe here also the zero
someone's like you showed in the
follow-up slide they attacked each other
less as well so maybe that's also a
reason why it fares better in this
specific environment so it might be yeah
exactly
they end up tagging each other less but
they also you know eventually like if
you let them go all the way to the end
of learning they do end up with
essentially a very similar policy
as as everybody else so they do they do
tag
um more than they use gifting towards
the end
yeah maybe the cleanup environment would
be interesting next thank you
let's see uh were there any more
questions
i guess i just had one very basic one so
i just want to double check so for the
the linear programming approach you were
talking about is this just based on like
optimizing over uh like occupancy
measures
yes indeed so the value function is
estimated based on the occupancy measure
yeah that makes sense okay cool cool
thanks
all right great um maybe we should stop
there so i think we'll have a quick
break until uh 3 30 and then we'll come
back for the last talks of the day and
let's uh thank joanna again that was
great
thank you very much thanks a lot